Durante las últimas décadas Chile ha sido
algo así como el Cristiano Ronaldo de América
Latina: el país que más crecía, que más
éxitos tenía, en definitiva, el que más
goles marcaba.
También para muchos liberales, Chile ha sido
durante años la referencia a seguir, creo
que podemos decir que veían al modelo chileno
como una especie de sueño en un mundo de
oscuras tinieblas.
Y lo cierto, amigos, es que hay buenos motivos
para tantos fuegos artificiales:
Chile que fue el territorio español más
pobre de Latinoamérica se ha convertido hoy
en el país más rico, en el país con más
esperanza de vida y en el país con el mayor
índice de desarrollo social de toda la región.
Es verdad, en Chile aún hay mucha desigualdad,
pero toda esta prosperidad ha beneficiado
a todos los colectivos del país. Por ejemplo,
en los últimos 25 años, el ingreso de los
más pobres ha crecido bastante más que el
de los más ricos y su capacidad de compra
se ha multiplicado por seis.
Pero ¿Qué supone todo esto si lo comparamos
con otros países latinoamericanos?
Pues fijaos: en 1950 el ingreso del chileno
promedio era prácticamente un tercio del
ingreso que tenía un venezolano, es decir,
los venezolanos eran tres veces más ricos.
Desde entonces las cosas, como creo que ya
os imagináis amigos de VisualPolitik, han
cambiado bastante y hoy los chilenos son mucho
más ricos que los venezolanos.
Y..., ojo, también tienen una esperanza de
vida bastante mayor. De media un chileno vive
8 años más que una persona nacida en Venezuela.
Vamos, que las cosas parece que se han hecho
relativamente bien.
Ahora la pregunta es ¿Cómo ha conseguido
Chile este cambio?
Pues básicamente apostando por buenas políticas
como impuestos comedidos, abriéndose al mundo,
Chile es el país con más acuerdos
comerciales o apostando por la libertad de empresa.
Todo esto lo vimos con más detalle en un
pasado vídeo, aquí en VisualPolitik, os
dejo el enlace en la descripción.
En ese vídeo Fonseca, nos alertaba de una
cosa: compararse con la Venezuela o la Argentina
de las últimas décadas es relativamente
fácil, pero cuando comparamos a Chile con
otros países, por ejemplo, de Asia… los
números ya no son tan bonitos y lo que es
peor… la máquina parece estar parándose.
En los últimos años, ese tiempo de vino,
champán y rosas durante el cual Chile parecía
comerse el mundo se ha terminado.
En Santiago de Chile, la gran capital del
país, las muestras de prosperidad han dejado
paso a manifestaciones y protestas. El enfado
y el desánimo es general, y... no es para
menos:
En los últimos años el crecimiento económico
se ha desplomado, en 2016 comenzó a destruirse
empleo, los salarios no crecen, entre los
jóvenes el desempleo está por las nubes
y tanto la inversión como las exportaciones
han caído abruptamente en los últimos años.
Y lo peor de todo es que las expectativas no son buenas.
Si a todo esto le sumamos que, a pesar de
todo el crecimiento, 3 de cada 4 chilenos
ganan menos de 700 dólares al mes, ya os
podéis imaginar el cabreo, porque, amigos,
esos salarios de país rico no tienen nada.
En otras palabras, hoy el modelo chileno hace
aguas.
Por cierto, para los que nos estéis
viendo desde Chile, quiero que sepáis que
aprecio mucho vuestro país. De hecho, estuve
una temporada viviendo muy cerquita de la
Moneda. Vamos que ni el mote con huesillo
ni las empanadas de pino me son cosas extrañas.
Pero volviendo al tema que nos ocupa. El principal
responsable de este frenazo tiene nombre y
apellido: Michelle Bachelet, la actual presidenta
de la República.
Algunos analistas comparan la evolución política
de Chile con la de España: ambos países
sufrieron una dura dictadura militar, seguida
de una transición donde primero gobernó
una izquierda moderada, luego la derecha,
y finalmente ambos terminaron con gobiernos
de una izquierda más rupturista.
Es decir, el papel de Felipe González sería
en Chile el de Patricio Aylwin, Eduardo Frei,
Ricardo Lagos y la propia Bachelet en su primera
etapa, y el papel de José María Aznar sería
el de Sebastián Piñera.
Bachelet hoy, en esta
última legislatura equivaldría en España
a José Luis Rodriguez Zapatero.
El caso es que en tras ganar las elecciones
presidenciales en 2013, y ser nombrada de
nuevo Presidenta, Michelle Bachelet puso en
marcha un programa mucho más agresivo, decidido
a incrementar el intervencionismo del gobierno
y el gasto público.
Y vaya si lo hizo.
Su primera gran apuesta, atentos, fue subir
los impuestos a las empresas casi un 40%.
Ahí es nada.
Lo hizo subiendo el tipo sobre beneficios
y eliminando también una bonificación por
la cual las empresas que reinvertían sus
beneficios en Chile reducían el pago de impuestos.
Si lo pensáis es muy razonable..
Un país como Chile que aún está lejos de
los países más ricos lo que necesita son
fábricas, máquinas, negocios, tecnología,
en definitiva, Inversión.
Así que ya me contaréis qué sentido tiene
castigar, precisamente eso, la inversión.
Pues eso es lo que hizo Bachelet.
Y, ojo, porque los impuestos a las empresas
en Chile no son precisamente bajos.
Tras la reforma de Bachelet, Chile es el
segundo país que en términos relativos más
impuestos cobra a las empresas, solo por detrás
de Japón, qué desde luego es un país mucho
más rico y con empresas mucho más consolidadas.
¿Queréis saber qué consecuencias ha tenido
está medida? Pues que la inversión se ha
desplomado un 30% desde que Bachelet regresó
al Palacio de la Moneda.
Y, claro, menos inversión supone menos empleos,
menos crecimiento y por tanto menos recaudación.
En otras palabras, el gobierno de Chile quiso
comerse el pastel antes siquiera de cocinarlo.
y eso, la verdad, nunca suele funcionar.
Por esta razón en últimos años hay una
tendencia a reducir los impuestos a las empresas:
Canadá, Reino Unido, Irlanda o incluso la
Francia de Macron son algunos ejemplos de
países que han reducido los impuestos corporativos
o planean hacerlo. Chile va en dirección
contraria.
Pero esperad un momento, porque aquí no acaba
todo. Las otras dos grandes reformas de Bachelet
han tenido un resultado similar. Abordaremos
estas reformas con profundidad en un próximo
vídeo pero de momento dos apuntes:
La reforma laboral ha encarecido la contratación
y se ha centrado en reforzar el poder de los
sindicatos. Todo esto puede sonar muy bien
pero supone aún más costes para las empresas,
lo que sumado a la subida que hemos visto
de los impuestos… pues… aun menos inversión,
menos competitividad y menos exportaciones.
Vamos, el cóctel completo.
Con la reforma educativa la Presidenta quiso
de facto nacionalizar las Universidades pero
esta reforma tampoco le ha salido bien y solo
ha podido aprobarla parcialmente.
Eso sí, tened una cosa muy presente, convertir a las universidades en fábricas de títulos
por muy gratuitas que sean no va a resolver los problemas de movilidad social que tiene hoy Chile
que es la verdadera enfermedad que afecta al país.
Pero puede que os esteis preguntado,  ¿qué
piensan los Chilenos? Pues atentos:
La sensación que existe, amigos, es que Bachelet
quería más a un cambio ideológico que una
formula que resolviese problemas.
El resultado de todas estas reformas y de
la aversión del gobierno por la empresa privada,
que ha generado mucha incertidumbre, ha sido
la peor legislatura en términos económicos
que Chile ha tenido en décadas.
Y ¿sabéis quién sale más perjudicado de
esta situación? Exacto, los más pobres y
la clase trabajadora. Al fin y al cabo, la
gente con dinero vive siempre bien.
El caso es que Bachelet deja un país en crisis,
con déficit públicos crecientes, con el
gasto público más elevado de los últimos
26 años y con un sector productivo muy tocado.
Por supuesto, la presidenta también se marcha
sin haber diversificado la economía ni haber
corregido sus problemas más importantes ¿Cuáles
son? Veámoslos.
Si algo es un hecho es que Chile es un país bastante hostil a los profesionales extranjeros.
Es raro que un país que ha crecido
tanto y que se ha convertido en el país más
rico de Latinoamérica haya sido incapaz de
atraer a profesionales de fuera.
Tan solo el 2% de la población chilena es
inmigrante y eso es un problema que afecta
al emprendimiento, a la innovación y al comercio.
Los profesionales extranjeros, por ejemplo,
tienden a ser más emprendedores lo que ayuda
a diversificar y a desarrollar la economía.
En el propio Chile los inmigrantes tienen
una tasa de emprendimiento que multiplica
por 4 a la de la población local.
Un segundo problema es que el ascensor social
no funciona. Esto es, no hay cambios entre
clases sociales. El que nace abajo muere abajo y el que nace arriba muere arriba.
De hecho, se dice que el país está de facto
controlado por apenas 7 familias cuya riqueza
equivale al 17% del PIB nacional.
Esto puede parecernos que no es importante,
pero cuando el ascensor social y la competencia
no funcionan significa que el apellido se
antepone al mérito y al esfuerzo. El coste
de oportunidad que esto tiene es enorme.
Por no hablar de que estas familias suelen
tener relaciones un tanto especiales con el
poder. Mirad, mirad:
Sí, a Bachelet también le ha salpicado la
corrupción.
Y luego, amigos, está la burocracia.
Seguro que habéis escuchado que Chile es
una economía muy libre… sí y cuando la
conoces también tienes claro que es muy burocrática.
¿no te lo crees? Solo tienes que intentar,
siendo extranjero, hacerte con un RUT, un
Rol Único Tributario, que es un documento
imprescindible para llevar a cabo operaciones
comerciales básicas como contratar internet
en tu casa. También puedes probar a abrirte
una cuenta bancaria.
Prueba y Buena suerte.
¿Otro ejemplo? La regulación chilena impide
incluso importar coches de segunda mano.
Mark Twain dijo que hay tres clases de mentiras:
las mentiras, las medias mentiras y las estadísticas.
Puede que los números de Chile tengan algo
de eso.
El caso es que el 19 de noviembre de 2017
se celebran elecciones. Aún no están decididos
los candidatos, pero hay dos claros favoritos:
Alejandro Guillier y Sebastián Piñera.
Alejandro Guillier es un periodista recién
llegado a la política cuyos planteamientos
no están muy claros, más allá de su pasión
por China. Pero eso sí, supone más de lo
mismo.
Por otro lado, Sebastián Piñera fue presidente
de Chile entre 2010 y 2014. Fue el primer
presidente de centro-derecha desde que Chile
recobró la democracia tras la terrible etapa
de Pinochet, y lo cierto es que su papel al
frente de la Moneda fue bastante positivo.
A pesar de la crisis financiera y del terrible
terremoto que el país padeció en
2010 el crecimiento económico de Chile en
su mandato fue el triple que el de Bachelet
en esta legislatura.
Algo está claro, si Chile quiere recobrar la buena marcha, amigos, tiene que virar el rumbo.
Bueno, tú ¿qué piensas? ¿Cómo valoras
a Bachelet? ¿Con quién irías, con Piñera
o Guilliar? Espero tus respuestas.
Si te ha gustado el vídeo dale a like y no
olvides suscribirte al canal. También aprovecho
para recordarte que puedes encontrarnos en
Facebook, twitter e Instagram.
Por cierto, os lo han dicho tanto Enrique
como Fonseca, pero yo también quiero daros
las gracias a todos aquellos que estáis echando
una mano a VisualPolitik con vuestras donaciones
en Paypal.
Gracias a vosotros podemos plantearnos hacer
muchas más cosas.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.